foreign
shop in azaz in Northern Syria since the
Civil War began he witnessed attacks by
isil and Kurdish Fighters the ypg the
past couple of years have been
relatively quiet but earlier this week
azaz was once again hit by Rockets
it was a bloody night I don't know when
we will get rid of this ypg terrorist
threat it's affecting business we hope
the Turkish military launches this
operation soon and restores safety
he is referring to a Turkish ground
operation into Northern Syria something
the government of reject type erdon has
hinted at with violence Rising along the
border and in Istanbul where a bombing
killed six people earlier this month
in the Border region some are concerned
for their safety
I live with this bomb threat because
there is no alternative or solution a
lot of civilians are paying a lot of
money to immigrate if I had other
options I wouldn't stay here
a Syrian Turkish businessman says the
fighting has halted trade education and
development on both sides of the Border
in case of instability I'm concerned
about families and children we syrians
and Turks and killers are intertwined we
built a life here and we won't leave
are nearly 16 kilometers apart the area
is the primary trade route the security
of one side is important for the other
that's why both sides of the Border seem
to support efforts to ensure the
Region's stability
[Music]
Southeastern turkey